- All right. Here's
the first song right now.
- ♪ All right, stop
- ♪ Oh, baby, baby
- ♪ Collaborate and listen
♪ Ice is back
with my brand new invention ♪
- Oh, ice something.
- ♪ Something
- ♪ Oh, baby, baby
- ♪ Grabs a hold of me
tightly ♪
♪ Flow like a harpoon
daily and nightly ♪
♪ Will it stop?
Yo, I don't know ♪
♪ Turn off the lights
and I'll glow ♪
- "Baby One More Time."
- Baby and then baby--
- ♪ Like a vandal
♪ Light up a stage and wax
a chump like a candle ♪
♪ Dance, go rush the speaker
that booms ♪
- What's the other one?
What's the other one?
Why am I forgetting?
Oh, my God, Blake.
Do you know it?
♪ Hold you tightly
♪ Flow like a harpoon
daily and nightly ♪
- All right.
[cheers and applause]
All right.
John and Kelly have buzzed in.
- Wait a minute.
I didn't know!
You didn't tell me
I had to buzz in!
- It's all right.
It doesn't matter.
- You're the worst host ever!
You didn't tell me
I had to buzz!
- We just started the show!
How can I be
the worst host ever?
Here we go,
they locked it in.
- It's so weird to me
that we knew you should buzz
in, and he didn't.
[laughter]
- Yeah, so surprising.
Let's see what we got here.
"Ice Ice Baby One More Time"!
That is correct!
For 1,000 points!
[cheers and applause]
- Please, guys,
do you have to--can you not--
- Let's just see--
let's just see
what you typed in.
- Blake typed this.
- "Hit Me Baby In Th Face."
[buzzer]
Now, Blake--
- I don't know--
- I want to see how you--
- I only knew one song!
- I had a feeling you did that.
- I did.
I just didn't understand.
- I only knew one song!
- I knew you were going--
I saw you typing
and I am offended.
- "Hit Me Baby In The Face"!
- "Hit Me Baby In The Face."
- You are the worst partner
ever.
- What?
[laughter and chatter]
- We just started,
we just started.
- Worst host, worst partner.
- Hey.
[audience exclaiming]
Wow!
- And worst crowd!
And worst crowd!
- What are you doing?
[laughter and applause]
- Wow.
- What are you doing?
- Playing up the
villain thing here.
- All right.
Here we go.
Here is the next one.
- Okay.
♪
- California.
- "California Dreamin'."
Right?
- Right.
- ♪ If you see a faded sign
on the side of the road ♪
♪ It says 15 miles to the...
- ♪ Love shack
- "Love Shack."
- ♪ Love shack, yeah
- What is that song?
"California Dreamin'."
Doesn't make sense!
- ♪ I got me a car
that's as big as a whale ♪
- No, no, no, no, no,
that's not that song!
- ♪ To the love shack
- Oh, my God, I know, Blake!
Forgetting!
Oh, my God!
[indistinct]
[cheers and applause]
- You're amazing!
- All right.
You locked in first.
Let's see what you wrote down.
"California Love Shack."
Correct! For 1,000 points!
[cheers and applause]
- Too easy!
- She said
"California Dreamin'."
- No, I did not!
- Did you just say me?
- You said that!
- Let me just see what you guys
wrote down just so we can--
Just a second.
[laughter]
- "Love Off BFF!"
- What is that?
Is that your credit card
number? Is that--
This is crazy.
[laughter]
All right, for this next one--
- We're warming up!
We're warming up.
- This next one is pretty--
- "We're warming up!"
- This one is--
- Don't, Kelly Clarkson.
[laughter]
- All right, Jam Band.
Whenever you're ready.
- Oh, my God, man.
[upbeat music]
- ♪ But you didn't have
to cut me off ♪
- You didn't have
to cut me off.
You didn't have to--
- ♪ I wanna dance
with somebody ♪
- ♪ It never happened
and that we were nothing ♪
- "I Wanna Love Somebody."
- That's "Somebody"--ooh!
- ♪ And I don't even need
your love ♪
♪ But you treat me
like a stranger ♪
- "I Wanna Dance With Somebody
That I Used To Know."
- ♪ No, you didn't have
to stoop so low ♪
- ♪ Oh, I wanna dance
with somebody ♪
- "Dance With Somebody
I Used to Know."
- ♪ Have your friends
collect your records ♪
- ♪ I wanna feel
the heat with somebody ♪
- ♪ And then change
your number ♪
- ♪ Yeah, I wanna dance
with somebody ♪
- ♪ I guess that
I don't need that, though ♪
♪ Now you're just somebody
that I used to know ♪
[laughter]
[cheers and applause]
- All right!
For the first time, Blake and
Ariana have buzzed in first!
They got a chance at this!
Let's see what you wrote down!
"I Wanna Dance
with Simebidy Iused Tijmow."
- Yes, yes!
- No!
- Yes!
- That's very--
[ding]
Yes!
- No, no!
[laughter and applause]
- Let's see
what you guys wrote.
- What?
- Typed correctly.
- "I Wanna Dance With Somebody
That I Used To Know."
That's--that is correct.
- What?
- But they buzzed in first.
All right.
- Correct spelling,
but a little too late.
[laughter]
- Oh, my God.
Says your education!
- We had to make it in time
is all.
- We're going to do
one more song.
This is worth 5,000 points,
and I'm going to see--
can I try this one?
I'm going--
[cheers and applause]
- Jimmy's gonna sing.
[applause]
- Oh, "Cry Me A River."
- "Cry Me A River."
♪
- ♪ Let's do it
- ♪ Right now,
I'm in a state of mind ♪
- Oh, my God.
♪ I wanna be in like
all the time ♪
♪ Ain't got no tears left
to cry ♪
♪ So I'm pickin' it up,
pickin' it up ♪
♪ I'm lovin', I'm livin',
I'm pickin' it up ♪
♪ I just want you
to come with me ♪
- ♪ Cry me a river
- ♪ We're
on another mentality ♪
- ♪ Cry me a river
- ♪ Ain't got no tears left
to cry ♪
♪ So I'm pickin' it up,
pickin' it up ♪
♪ I'm lovin', I'm livin',
I'm pickin' it up ♪
♪
[cheers and applause]
All right.
Who buzzed in first?
- I hope it was us.
- It was Blake and Ariana!
- Oh, really?
[cheers and applause]
- I hope you guys got this one.
All right, let's see
what you wrote down.
- I really hope--
- "No Tears Left
To Cry Me A River!"
Correct, for 5,000 points!
- [indistinct]
- You're back in the game!
You're back in the game!
Let's just see
what you typed in.
It was very close.
- Except for the thousand
you still gave them,
but that's fine.
- It's a close game right now.